So how does machine learning actually
differ from traditional programming?
Well when we write
a traditional program,
we usually build the decision-making
directly into the program.
So if we wanted to develop a program
that could recognize my face.
We would tell it, look for glasses, look
for brown eyes, look for brown hair.
With machine learning though, we
wouldn't actually tell it any of that.
We would build an agent that could look
at a bunch of images over time, and
figure out who I am on its own.
We would give it a bunch
of pictures of myself and
a bunch of pictures of other people and
let it figure out on its own.
Hey, he's the guy with the brown hair,
and the brown eyes and the glasses.
Now setting apart machine
learning also is the fact that,
it's only recently become feasible for
us to be able to address
these very large data sets
with computational methods.
Computers have finally come along and
become fast enough to be able to address
the kinds of data sets that
we have available to us now.
And also helping it is the fact that the
world is more reliant on computers than
ever before, so
much data is generated kind of
automatically while people are going
about their everyday lives.
So these things really unite to make
machine learning a much more useful tool
right now than it would
have ever been before.